Before I begin,
I just wanted to say that I was very,
uh,
I found,
last,
uh,
periods lecture with a David Swensen.
Very interesting.
Also,
I liked being serenaded by new blue.
She's the first experience for me.
Um,
but uh,
it's,
and um,
he gave a,
I thought a very interesting talk cause I've heard him talk before,
but it's always interesting.
Um,
he,
he really emphasized diversification.
Um,
but you know,
I don't know what you were thinking.
We got a 28% portfolio return last year.
There's something else going on besides diversification.
Right?
Diversification means you get the average return.
Um,
and I was glad that you asked questions at the answer of your questions seem to
draw out other things that he doesn't plan to talk about.
Uh,
like what he really did to make money.
And so,
um,
one thing was that he said that they shorted the Internet stocks in the late
1990s as a brilliant market timing device that I think enlightened people
thought that those prices were getting high.
Uh,
and also made some play on credit spreads a and now on a real estate.
He said,
so,
uh,
how does he do it?
Uh,
again,
uh,
it's my theory that there's no,
you can't entirely be taught,
but,
uh,
partly though I think that he does it and as do other a good portfolio managers
by just keeping a very broad base of knowledge and listening to people and
collecting information and watching the big trends and thinking about them.
Uh,
so one of I think a Swenson's best talents is his,
is a good listener and he incorporates a basic facts and acts on them.
So you might have,
it would be incorrect,
I think in listening to what he said to conclude that he just says diversify,
uh,
because he's obviously done something very different from that.
So,
um,
by the way,
I have another speaker who told me that he would like to talk to our class and I
hope we can work it out.
Uh,
his name is Carl Icahn who is,
uh,
one of the biggest Wall Street,
powerful and enlightened people on Wall Street who can also maybe tell us
something about how he makes money or how he makes it a better world.
Uh,
but the problem is that he has,
uh,
you know,
these people have very tight schedules and he's involved in various takeovers
and things right now.
So,
um,
he said,
he could do,
if we could arrange to meet after 3:00 PM.
Um,
so,
uh,
I'm going to,
is that like on a Monday or a Wednesday,
perhaps out of 3:00 PM,
uh,
or,
or later,
he said it might even,
uh,
his assistant said it might even be 7:00 PM.
So that's the way he works.
I don't think he gets up at 9:00 AM apparently.
Um,
so,
um,
uh,
I take that that's all right with you that you can come to a special,
section of this class,
but we have to see if we can arrange that.
Uh,
and you know,
again,
I don't guarantee that it will happen because the reality is someone who is
involved in as many things as he is,
it's going to be something.
Um,
but we do have a Stephen Schwarzman Carme,
um,
February 22nd,
and,
uh,
um,
and we have,
uh,
Andrea red leaf coming March 5th.
So,
uh,
we have a really strong set of outside speakers,
this year.
And again,
the midterm exam is Monday.
Uh,
sorry that I missed stated that last week.
but you've already seen last year was midterm and it's gonna look a lot like
that.
Um,
uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
so we're talking today about interest rates,
and uh,
uh,
bonds.
Interest rates are an old,
old thing.
They go back to ancient times.
Um,
but,
uh,
I'm going to talk about some of our modern institutions and I'm going to talk
first about discount bonds.
This is a little bit more of a technical lecture,
um,
but,
I find it just as interesting myself as a,
but what we're talking about,
discount bonds,
uh,
and then a coupon carrying bonds.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
talk about the term structure of interest rates.
Uh,
and uh,
why,
why we have interest rates.
Uh,
I think that's my blackberry
VP.
I'm trying not to live in,
to electronic,
uh,
were,
that's the way it is these days.
Okay.
Uh,
this is beef.
It's giving you,
it's last,
last gas.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
finally talk about inflation index bonds.
So,
uh,
okay.
Uh,
the first,
uh,
thing is,
um,
is a,
uh,
a discount bond.
It's the most simple,
simple,
uh,
or often called a bill.
Okay?
A discount bond,
uh,
does not pay interest.
It's sold at a discount,
okay?
So you have the principal,
uh,
which is the amount owed,
which is,
let's say it's $100,
uh,
and that will be paid to you at some date in the future.
It's specified in the contract,
uh,
and,
nothing.
You'd just get $100,
but you get effectively,
you get interest from this because it's sold at a discount.
So the price that you pay is equal to 100 minus the discount.
All right?
So you wouldn't buy this bond at par because at power,
meaning at $100,
because then you wouldn't get any interest on it.
So you buy it at a discount,
uh,
and,
and that,
uh,
the,
the return you get is of course,
a hundred minus.
Oh,
uh,
yeah,
the return you get is the discount.
Okay.
So the u s government is a big issuer of discount bonds and they're called
treasury bills.
So I have them up on the screen here.
This is from a US government website called how a Treasury treasurydirect.gov
and you can get on and access it at any time.
Um,
and it is showing since the u s government issues these bonds,
it's,
it's showing its data on these bonds.
The bonds are auctioned off on regular date.
Uh,
and uh,
you cannot participate in the auction.
I assume you can't,
you'd have to be an authorized participant,
but if you become an institution,
you can get authorized to trade in the,
in the auction.
So these are the dates.
The latest auction,
uh,
was,
February 14,
uh,
I guess that was yesterday,
right?
Uh,
and the,
the term means it was a 60 day,
a treasury bill.
That means it pays a not a $100.
Uh,
it would start at $10,000 a treasury bills.
Yep.
Maybe you have to realize there's a distinction between savings bonds and
tertiary rebuild.
Treasury bills are for serious investors,
and so they don't come small denominations.
The U s government also issues small denomination that,
uh,
two individuals to help them called savings bonds.
Um,
but,
uh,
we aren't talking about those.
Uh,
so,
um,
at the,
uh,
February 14th auction,
treasury bills were 60 day treasury bills were sold,
uh,
and the,
the auction prices given.
Well,
here's the price of the bill.
Uh,
the issue date was,
uh,
today,
February 15,
uh,
and they mature in what should be exactly 60 days in April 15.
Um,
so,
uh,
if you want to buy one,
you would pay this price.
This number CUSIP number is a number which identifies any security.
It's like you have a social security number or other ID number,
which positively,
and there might be another person with the same name as you,
God forbid,
but you at least have your own number,
which is guaranteed to be identical,
uh,
unique to you.
So every security has an identical CUSIP which identifies it.
Um,
so I want to just to start by explaining the numbers here.
how did they get,
how do these numbers inter relate?
Uh,
okay.
Well,
um,
this,
uh,
the discount rate is w is sort of the entry.
You notice there's two different interest rates here and you might be confused
by them.
The discount rate,
uh,
that is shown a is the number that you plug in to a formula to get the price.
What really matters to you as an investor is how much you have to pay today to
get $100,
uh,
in,
in 60 days.
Okay.
Uh,
so how do we get the price,
uh,
from the discount rate?
Uh,
well,
there's an a formula that's been used,
um,
by,
uh,
um,
bond traders for hundreds of years.
Uh,
and it,
it's a traditional expression,
which goes from the discount rate to the price.
And in this case,
price is 99.58.
And what does that equal?
It equals 2.51.
That's the discount rate that you see up there,
but 2.51 um,
times 60 divided by 360.
Okay.
Uh,
as you know,
there's the thing,
maturity is 60 days and as you know,
there are about 360 days in a year.
And so,
uh,
by tradition they divide by 360,
not 365.
Um,
and so you understand that,
uh,
dealers tend to have treasury bills tend to quote discounts a,
that's a way it's like a language and a language of finance.
Okay.
And so,
uh,
what,
what they,
everybody knows is that the discount is converted into a price according to this
formula.
And so,
um,
uh,
you might ask what,
is this an approximate formula?
No,
it's an exact formula.
Uh,
but then you say,
well,
why didn't they divide by 365?
Because we,
I know there's 365 days in a year.
Okay.
Uh,
well,
the answer is this goes way back.
It's an old tradition.
And they used to have to do this by hand.
They had to divide by hand.
And so they didn't like the number 365,
so they thought,
let's just round it to 360.
And as long as everybody knows that's what we're doing,
what difference does it make?
Right?
Okay.
So that's what you're supposed to know.
So if you're the other quotes you a discount rate of 2.51%,
you know how to convert that into the price and that's all that mattered.
All that really matters is the price you have to pay.
Um,
now they also have something up here called the investment rate.
Yes.
Oh,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
Brad,
you,
Oh
yeah,
I'm sorry.
That's the difference between one and 99.5.
Yes.
Thank you.
Uh,
uh,
between 199.58.
Okay.
Are you okay now?
Sorry,
I made,
uh Huh.
Okay.
Now the thing is to convert that into what is this other,
this,
that was another interest rate up there called the investment rate.
Uh,
well that's the,
that's supposed to be your percentage return on an annualized basis.
Remember,
this thing only runs for 60 days and you could cook,
compute your 60 day return.
But people like to compare annual.
That's again,
a tradition that we have and there's nothing special about annual.
That's the time it takes the earth to go around the sun,
but it doesn't have any relevance to finance.
But,
uh,
we are just accustomed to using that.
So,
uh,
we,
what we're going to do,
however,
is KP kind of another problem.
And that is,
um,
you might think that,
uh,
this quantity here is,
is my,
uh,
return.
Um,
but you have to actually divided by the price,
which is less than a hundred to get a return.
Uh,
you're not putting in $100 to this investment.
You're putting in $99.58 for the investment and you're getting out the
difference between 199.58.
Uh,
and so that is not,
uh,
your return is actually higher than 2.51% on an annualized basis.
So what we do,
our show you how they got their number,
um,
2.5629999999999997 a,
which is the,
uh,
the number you see under a investment rate is equal to one all over 0.9,
nine five,
eight minus one corrected for the number of days in a year.
Um,
and how do we do that correction?
Uh,
when I first tried this,
I thought fine,
I'll,
I'll multiply by 365 over 60,
but I forgot this is a leap year and so times 366,
Oliver 60.
So that's how you go from,
um,
the discount yield,
the discount rate to the investment rate.
They understand why we had to do this.
Uh,
the investment rate is telling you how much money you're really making on an
annualized basis.
And so it's very simple.
I put in a 0.99,
five,
eight for every dollar I got out.
So my appreciation of my money is one over 0.9,
nine five,
eight,
right?
Subtract that by $1,
which is what I put in.
And that's how much money I made as,
as a fraction of a dollar.
Right?
All I have to do then is correct that for the number of days in a year.
And so that's,
that's what I did.
That's how we go from the discount rate to the investment rate.
Now you might ask,
well,
if we did 360 here,
why don't we just do the 360 over here?
Well,
it's one of the mysteries of Wall Street.
Uh,
they'd like to,
when their computer in the investment,
you know,
they want to be completely honest and not use any rules of thumb.
Uh,
so you have to understand that it's 360 here because that's just a convention
and everybody knows that that's just the way we quote prices.
Rather than say a 99 and 58 cents,
we just quote the 2.51 and everybody knows how to convert.
But when you ask for the investment rate,
you want to know the truth.
How much am I really getting?
So they don't monkey around here.
Also,
they don't have to actually,
you know,
in the old days,
they didn't actually have to compute the investment rate.
If you were talking to your broker,
if you've got a really old days,
you'd send a boy running over to your broker.
They didn't have telephones.
And I used to have runners and the boy,
we'd go say,
uh,
we're,
we're offering to pay a discount rate of 2.5.
Well,
and that was the formula.
Um,
and then anyone could do these calculations.
They knew what it meant.
Um,
but,
um,
this calculation wasn't done very frequently.
That's just if you had one of the satisfaction of knowing how much money you're
making.
Okay.
So,
um,
okay,
so I think we pretty much explained,
well there's another thing I wanted to say about treasury bills.
Uh,
I used to have up here at page,
I used to take instead of treasury direct,
which is a website I used to get a clipping from the Wall Street Journal that
showed much the same information that you see on this chart,
but it showed additional information that you won't find on territory redirect.
It showed bid and asked for dealers.
Now you have to understand that treasury has these auctions only on these dates.
On,
uh,
February 14,
they only sold 60 day ones,
nothing else.
And on February 11th,
they sold only a 13 week ones and nothing else.
All right.
And so what if you want to buy a treasury bill on some other day,
but you can go to treasury direct as an individual and buy a treasury bill,
but it may not be the best place to buy.
What you normally do is you go to a dealer and the dealer is someone,
a professional who participated in the auction and bought these up to accumulate
an inventory to then sell off to you the customer.
So normally you don't deal with treasury direct,
you deal with a dealer.
Okay.
The Wall Street Journal calls around to the dealer,
which has an inventory of all these different maturities and ask them for their
bid and asked,
okay.
And a dealer,
that's what a dealer does,
is it maintains an inventory of,
in this case,
treasury bills,
uh,
and then it,
it,
uh,
stands ready to buy and sell.
So the bid price is the why they don't do it in terms of price and do it in
terms of discount.
So the bid discount,
right,
where there'd be two numbers for each one is the bid,
which is what they'll pay you
for a treasury bill.
If you want to sell to them,
uh,
and the asked is what you have to pay them through this formula.
The formula is,
I could write it this way.
Price
price equals 100 minus this.
Um,
and so,
uh,
normally when you have a dealer,
the dealer has a,
when when we talk in terms of price,
the dealer has a asked which is higher than the bid,
right?
If you go to an antique dealer,
maybe are familiar,
we have,
or maybe you've done this,
if you bought furniture for some apartment or something,
the,
the dealer will charge a higher price for you to buy the furniture.
Then we'll give to you to uh,
to purchase the furniture from you.
And that's how the dealer makes a difference.
It's the difference between bid and asked is the,
is the profit for the dealer and the bid ask spread is the profit for the
dealer.
So you can see these on the,
you can see the bid and ask on the Wall Street Journal.
Uh,
uh,
and,
it's interesting to look at it because you note that the bid ask spread,
which is the difference between the bid and the ask for a dealer,
uh,
is narrower in the more liquid securities.
Uh,
and some of the securities that are small and unimportant have a wide bid ask
spread.
That means that it's,
it's harder to make a market for it to,
the dealer wants to charge more.
Uh,
but this doesn't show this here.
Um,
uh,
unfortunately the Wall Street Journal stopped carrying this.
Um,
and I thought that's an interesting story about what goes on.
it's,
uh,
the,
the Wall Street Journal is the most influential financial publication in this
country.
Um,
but it has been going through financial difficulties with the Internet age.
Uh,
and in the last five years,
the stock in Dow Jones company has fallen by half a.
And what's happening?
Well,
I,
there are many factors,
but one important factor is the rise of the Internet,
uh,
has competed with people used to buy the Wall Street Journal to get data like
this.
Right?
But you see how I completely bypass the Wall Street Journal and I went to
treasury direct,
there's a million websites that give away financial data.
So,
uh,
so the Wall Street Journal,
was not doing as well.
Uh,
and do you know what happened?
finally,
uh,
well I'll give this as a saga.
They reduced the size of the newspaper in uh,
2005.
It used to be a big broad sheet and they made it smaller in 2005 and they start,
they keep cutting out.
Data is less and less data in the Wall Street Journal.
It used to be this big thick thing and you would go there every day to look up
price and everything was in there.
But now the web is competing with it.
So,
so there,
there's scaling down the sides of the paper,
uh,
and trying to survive.
Um,
and so they created Wall Street Journal Online,
which is a wsj.com.
Uh,
and they were trying to make money off of that,
but people weren't willing to pay for it.
You know how it is on the web.
You can get so much for free.
Why should I pay for wsj.com?
Uh,
and so that wasn't working well.
And so,
um,
last year,
about one year ago,
they announced Wall Street journal.com is absolutely free and we're going to
give away all the data,
basically all the data that used to be in the newspaper,
free to anyone.
Uh,
and I thought that was great.
now we can all get the Wall Street Journal without paying for it,
but there's some problem with that.
It's not an economic,
uh,
so this is not be too jubilant.
Uh,
what ended up happening is they know that the news that a Rupert Murdoch bought
the Wall Street Journal last fall,
uh,
and he announced that a Wall Street Journal wsj.com will no longer be free.
And so this is the reality of the,
of the world.
Uh,
I thought it was interesting.
If you look at,
uh,
a Rupert Murdoch,
this is finance at,
this may sound like an aside,
but this is all financing.
Rupert Murdoch,
uh,
you may have heard of him,
is a huge newspaper baron who buys up newspapers all over the world.
Uh,
and uh,
it's interesting he's been at,
but he's continuing what his father did it take to become the biggest publishing
monolith in the world.
It takes maybe a hundred years.
So his father in Australia started buying up newspapers.
Uh,
his father was born in 1886,
and now Rupert Murdoch is continuing.
He's now,
Rupert Murdoch is in his seventies,
and he's still buying this papers,
but he kind of makes them survive and Newscorp doubled its price.
That's his company doubled in the last,
uh,
in the last five years.
So you can see this is how the,
the unseen root role of Finance,
Wall Street Journal is a venerable newspaper and source of information about
finance.
But it's not making money.
The world is changing and Wall Street Journal is flagging.
So newscorp who's priced doubles when Wall Street Journal's fell in,
half eats advising and Wall Street Journal has gobbled up by the bigger rather
bigger company.
You can see why stock prices matter.
The,
the,
the News Corp's rising stock price was assigned that Rupert Murdoch had some
idea how to,
how to make money and Wall Street Journal was not doing as well.
So it got gobbled up.
Uh,
uh,
the question is what will happen to the Wall Street Journal now?
Um,
uh,
so,
well they have to make money.
That's the real world.
And so Rupert Murdoch tends to bring papers around.
I'm just going to go a little bit further on.
Rupert Murdoch bought the Times of London in 1981 that was 27 years ago.
The Times of London is one of the most venerable newspapers of the world,
and it was losing money fast and it might have disappeared if Murdoch hadn't
taken over.
Uh,
but Murdoch turned it around and it's still around.
They turned it into a tabloid and like it was the most dignified newspaper in
the world.
Uh,
and he kind of decided that in order to survive they had to get a little bit
more down to Earth.
Uh,
so they reduced the size.
So it looks like one of those like New York Daily News newspapers now,
but it's still a great newspaper.
Uh,
they,
he added celebrity gossip to which the London Times would never do in the past,
but you've got to do it right.
There's the thing about the real world and finance is very much about the real
world.
Uh,
and so Murdoch claims he will not alter the editorial content of the Wall Street
Journal.
Uh,
the thing that we see them doing is charging more.
Okay.
But I guess we got to allow that.
So we may feel annoyed that we now have to pay to get on Wall Street Journal
Online.
Uh,
but,
um,
but in the long run we want the Wall Street Journal.
And so,
um,
and so I guess that we just have to accept that.
So if you weren't a fine,
by the way,
if you want to read the Wall Street Journal online at Yale,
you can do it.
No problem.
You go to Abi inform,
which is one of the things at Yale subscribes to on your laptop and it puts you
right into the text of the Wall Street Journal.
Uh,
but it doesn't put you in as far as I can tell in the Wall Street Journal
Online.
So,
um,
we have other,
uh,
lots of data sources that Yale subscribes to and there's lots of free data
sources,
but,
uh,
Wall Street Journal is not free.
Anyway.
Um,
I wanted to talk to you understand now about a discount.
It's pretty simple,
right?
Um,
but I just wanted to get the pricing formula.
The critical thing about a discount bond is it pays no interest.
Treasury bills in the United States are limited to one year out,
but well that's the name of it.
Um,
so,
uh,
we call a,
an instrument of the u s treasury with a maturity less than or up less than or
equal to one year.
We call that a bill.
Um,
and they used to be the only discount bonds issued by the u s government.
now they also have longer maturity called treasury strips.
But,
uh,
there,
let me move though to the other.
Uh,
so we have u s government issues,
bills and so that's less than or equal to one year
and they pay no interest.
They also have government issues,
notes,
and that's from one to 10 years.
And bonds,
this is just jargon.
These are 10 or more.
Well,
actually more than 10.
I'll show you,
uh,
from Treasury direct,
I have notes.
Um,
this should be greater than 10.
Uh,
these are the,
uh,
recent auctions,
of the treasury of,
of,
um,
notes.
Okay.
Now these are different from bill's as I emphasized because they pay interest,
they carry what's called a coupon.
Um,
and uh,
and then we have the burns.
Uh,
and then you see there aren't as many of these issues.
We issue a lot of,
there's a lot of auctions of treasury bills,
uh,
and there are comparatively fewer of bonds.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
okay,
so,
uh,
let's talk about a bond.
A bond differs from a bill,
uh,
in that it carries what's called a coupon,
which I want to know by the letter c.
Uh,
and it has a principle which
it pays out at the end of 100.
Okay.
Uh,
of course they would be larger denominations than a hundred,
but by tradition we speak of them as if they were a vans that paid,
you paid $100 to get.
Okay.
Now another Wall Street tradition is that bonds pay prince,
they pay a coupon,
they pay c over to every six months.
So,
uh,
the coupon is at express as an annual amount.
You get half of it every six months.
Um,
and so,
uh,
the reason they call it coupons is that in the old days you used to actually,
when you bought a bond,
there'd be a piece of paper and the piece of paper would have attached to it a
lot of little coupons that you would clip.
Uh,
and each one,
if it was a 20 year bond,
there would be 40 coupons,
one for each six month period,
and each one would have a date on it.
And what you used to do is every six months you'd pull out your bonds and you'd
clip the coupons with a pair of scissors.
And you'd take them to a bank and they would give you cash for your coupons.
Uh,
so we still call them coupons,
but now we don't do it.
We do things electronically.
You don't have to clip coupons anymore,
but if you want to see a bonds as it used to look,
uh,
with their coupons,
there are a number of them at the International Center for finance down the
street here.
Um,
on that way,
uh,
with their coupons still attached.
So the A,
they've got a lot of uh,
[inaudible] and get ruined her collectors of old bonds and they've got lots of
bonds with their coupons.
Still a,
you know what that means when a frame there on the wall with their coupons still
attached,
it means the company went bankrupt and never paid otherwise the coupons would
have been clipped.
So it's actually our international center for finance is sort of a museum for
defaulted bond and the ones that are beautiful for framing of the ones that
fail.
Um,
so you can see all the coupons.
Some of them have some of the coupons clipped and then then they stopped.
And you know,
there was bad news,
uh,
when they stopped clipping them,
we still call them coupons.
So if you have a bond with a,
um,
uh,
interest rate of 4.3,
seven,
5%,
that's not an easy one to divide by two,
but you would,
you would get half of that every six months,
uh,
until maturity.
Um,
and so we have to ask then,
uh,
how do we get the,
um,
uh,
how do we get the price in the yield from this?
Um,
so what we do is we take the interest rate,
which are called R and plug it into a formula,
which I didn't,
uh,
I didn't actually do the arithmetic
check,
uh,
check their number,
but the price,
um,
okay.
The price is just the,
uh,
the present value of the coupons,
at the interest rate are,
so the price of land
is present discounted value of and
principal
at,
uh,
at right are okay.
No,
you have to understand that when you buy a bond,
if you buy it at issue,
you get the first coupon in six months,
the second coupon in one year,
the third coupon in 18 months,
and the last coupon you get at the maturity date.
So that means what is the stream of payments you get?
See over two and six months,
see over to again and a year see over to again in 18 months.
And that continues until the last date,
the maturity date when you get 100 plus c over to
okay.
And so the price is just the present value,
uh,
of the,
of that stream discounted at the interest rate.
Uh,
and so the formula can also be written if you expand it out,
price is equal to a see over two
times
one over r over to,
um,
which has the,
uh,
what the console formula if this were applied,
to an incident stream minus one over one plus r over to two,
the two t power times one over r over too.
Uh,
I'm making,
let's make sure I've got this right.
Uh,
plus 100 times one.
All over one plus r over to to the two t power.
Okay.
This should be obvious if I did that right.
This should be obvious from what you've learned about in present value formulas.
MMM.
If you had a perpetuity which paid see over to forever,
you already know from the perpetuity formula,
that's the value of that would be see over two divided by r over to,
um,
if our over two is the discount,
right?
But it's not forever because it terminates at after,
uh,
after two t periods,
of six months interval each so that you,
you want to subtract off the value of a perpetuity that,
uh,
starts after two t six months intervals.
And so this is the present value of the perpetuity that starts,
uh,
after two t six months intervals.
Then you want to add the present value of the principal.
Okay?
And so that's the formula and that's another conventional formula that goes from
interest rate to price of the other security.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
so,
um,
okay.
No,
I want it to talk about the term structure of interest rates.
Uh,
and that's my next plot here.
that's the term structure.
As of now on the chart,
we've identified the prices and yields of
bonds of various maturities.
Uh,
how do the
prices and yields look,
uh,
at various points in time.
And so I've got here term structure,
well she term structure
is the applause,
a yield to maturity against time to maturity.
Uh,
this is,
um,
January of this year before the Fed cut interest rates.
Uh,
and this is the term structure.
I've got a,
the federal funds rate is the shortest interest rate.
It's an overnight rate.
It was at 4% at that time.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
there was a sharp drop.
The three month treasury bill rate is shown there.
It was much lower.
It was under 3%.
And then the,
uh,
the,
so the term structure was downward sloping until about two and a half years.
And then it was upward sloping.
The interesting question from the standpoint of economic theory is why did it
have that funny shape?
Uh,
I wanted to compare it with other,
um,
other,
uh,
examples of the term structure,
recently.
Uh,
this is the term structure.
Just a short while ago,
December,
2006 very different,
right?
The uh,
federal funds rate was a five and a half.
And then the whole term structure all the way almost thought,
well,
there's this funny funny glitch here between uh,
uh,
three months in one year,
but then it just continued to decline.
That's a strong leader,
downward sloping term structure.
Uh,
and this is another example not so long ago.
This is December,
2003.
Now the term structure was pretty much upward sloping everywhere.
So,
uh,
at that time the Fed had cut the federal funds rate to 1%.
We had very low short rates.
Uh,
and the three month treasury bill rate was about the same at 1%,
but going further out,
the term structure just kept rising.
It's one of the questions of economics is what determines the term structure.
You have to understand that it's determined in the market.
The,
uh,
the,
the Fed has these auctions,
but it auctions them off at what price the public will.
Hey,
so the Fed doesn't determine the term structure.
Neither did the dealer is determined the term structure.
The dealers have to buy and sell at prices that are in the market.
It has to stay relevant to the market.
So nobody really knows where these interest rates come from because no one
person sets them.
If you're a dealer,
you've got to keep your bid asked at market.
Otherwise you'll get only one side of the other,
right?
Uh,
you'll be selling too cheaply or you'll be buying two dearly.
you got to,
you've got to do it.
So you're right in the middle so that the market is in the middle.
So nobody really sees the reason for that.
It's all a question of theory.
So we have to think a little bit about theory.
So,
um,
the term structure is one of the most interesting things in economics because it
shows the price of time,
uh,
at various maturity.
So in,
in 2003,
uh,
time was almost free,
out three months.
Uh,
it didn't,
if you,
if you needed more time to get some business done,
you'd have to bow,
but you don't have to pay 1% a year.
That would be like a quarter of 1% to postpone your payment by another year.
So time was really cheap.
Uh,
but uh,
but if you wanted to postpone it over seven years,
so time got a lot more expensive.
So why is this and why is the price of time changing?
Uh,
one thing to do is they just asked to go back and ask what really are,
um,
mmm,
the reasons for interest.
Uh,
and I wanted to talk about the theory of the interest,
uh,
as presented by a Professor Irving Fisher.
Yeah.
Who is famous having expositive back.
And I fell,
I imagine he did it at this very blackboard because they said he had his office
in this building.
Uh,
uh,
and,
he didn't die until 1940s.
So he must've been in this building was this room goes back to the 30s.
So,
um,
uh,
he had a diagram which illustrated what,
is the ultimate cause of interest.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it helps us to think about this diagram whenever we try to understand the term
structure.
So he did what his diagram.
Uh,
this is the famous Irving Fisher Diagram,
uh,
depicted a world in which there's only one period there is today,
on this access and,
uh,
tomorrow,
well,
I shouldn't say tomorrow that suggest one day.
Next period on this axis,
uh,
let's say it's one year,
okay?
And I'm going to actually plot on this axis,
um,
a person's income this year.
I should say income today on this axis
and on this,
uh,
income next period.
So for each person,
there is a point representing my income today and my income next period.
Let's assume that I know what I'm earning next year.
Okay?
There's actually uncertainty about it.
All right?
So if I draw this down,
this,
this point is ti this year,
his income down here and this point here is a next year's income.
I,
I'll use Y for income.
This is why today,
and this is why next period.
Um,
so I person has a budget constraint.
If the person can borrow and lend,
uh,
at the interest rate,
and the budget constraint is a straight line through this point,
uh,
with a slope of one plus r.
So I'll try to draw this line.
Okay?
That should be a straight line.
It doesn't look that straight cause I was running out of room.
Uh,
but you see it,
that's,
that's a straight line.
Okay.
Uh,
this point here then is the present value of your income,
right?
So it's why today
a plus y next period,
however one
are,
okay.
Now,
what's this point up here?
This point up here is the terminal value of my income.
Uh,
and so the or the upper point is,
uh,
why today
times one Plus r plus y next.
Now,
in an ideal world where you can borrow and lend freely,
uh,
an individual could choose consumption along any point on this day,
on this line,
right?
I could consume all of my income.
If I borrow against my future income,
I could.
There's a problem here of starvation.
If I consume it all this year,
I would be starving.
I don't see how I can earn income next year.
Uh,
but in principle,
that's what Irving Fisher said,
or I could just not consume anything this year and I could wait until next year
and consume the terminal value.
I would take my income this year,
invested at the interest rate,
and it would turn into y today times one plus r and then I get income next year.
So I could consume all that so I can consume it any point along that vine as
well.
I could consume that today's income where I could consume here or I consume down
here.
Right?
If I consume less than I income today,
I'm saving,
uh,
and my consumption would be lower this year.
Am I doing that right?
No.
If I'm,
if I'm saving this year,
my consumption would be less than my income.
So my consumption might be here,
uh,
and I would then have more next year.
Okay.
That's so each individual reaches a decision.
Each individual has a,
uh,
an income point and decides how much to consume based on the budget constraint.
Um,
now the interest rate in Irving Fisher is world has to equate supply and demand
in the market for that.
Each person who wants to,
uh,
to,
to borrow has to be met by somebody else who wants to learn.
Uh,
and so the interest rate that we have in society is the compromise.
It's the interest rate that equates the,
that clears the market for loans.
Uh,
and that interest rate,
uh,
determines the market interest rate so that nobody can see the interest rate.
Why the interest rates at the level it is,
um,
uh,
in the market because nobody can see all of these individuals.
But that's why the interest rate gets determined and is,
uh,
is,
um,
uh Huh.
An equilibrium.
Why the interest rate,
uh,
clear as,
well,
it's,
it's a mysterious because it's a market phenomenon and each person only sees his
or her own contribution to the market and not the whole market.
Irving Fisher also drew on the curve and production possibility frontier for
society,
which he made downward curve.
This is production possibility
front here.
And that is a curve.
You've seen these before and economics that says,
uh,
how the production of our society can,
um,
can produce different combinations of income this year and next year.
If there were no credit markets society,
everyone would have to be on the production possibility frontier,
there'd be no other choice.
But if we have credit markets,
then people can individually choose to be on off the production reduction
possibility frontier and at a higher level of consumption then otherwise would.
And so you might have some people up here who are saving and other people down
here who are this saving,
uh,
and the production will be operating at the middle.
Uh,
so that is Irvin Fischer's diagram,
uh,
in a nutshell.
But,
uh,
I think it's,
um,
it's,
uh,
so what,
what does it say about the term structure?
It says that at different horizons,
everything on this diagram is different.
So,
uh,
the production possibilities,
frontier at different horizons is in different places.
The budget constraint,
it's going to have different,
a slope to it and,
and preferences will be different over this horizon between consumption and
then,
and consumption.
Now.
So you,
it,
it doesn't,
this theory doesn't say a whole lot about what the term structure will look
like,
but it,
uh,
it,
suggest that it's determined by the interplay of lots of economic factors.
Uh,
so,
all right.
So,
um,
I wanted to talk about a couple of other basic concepts in economics of interest
rates.
Uh,
and one of them is the forward rate.
The other one is inflation indexed interest rates.
So,
um,
forward rates.
I wrote an article,
I wrote a survey Erica years ago about the term structure of interest rates and
I wanted to find out who was the originator of the term forward rate.
Uh,
so I asked my graduate student research assistant to research the whole
literature and find out where did the word forward rate come from.
And my graduate student came back and said,
it seems to have been served on Hicks in London and his 1931,
1939 book of value in capital.
All right.
But,
um,
I,
this is another aside,
but I think it's motivational.
And,
uh,
so,
I said,
are you sure that Jr Hixon invented the term forward?
Right?
And he said,
how can I be sure?
Right?
I mean,
I've looked through everything,
I can't find any earlier reference.
Um,
and he said,
I think it's j Hicks.
Um,
then I,
I was talking it over with another graduate student.
He said,
well,
if you want to find out,
why don't you ask Jr Hicks?
And so I said,
wait a minute,
is that guy still alive?
And he said,
I think he is.
Uh,
so I found out he was living in London,
Lord Hicks,
I guess he got knighted for his contribution.
And I wrote him a letter and I said,
basically,
did you invent forward rates?
Yeah,
yeah.
I didn't get any response for like three months.
And then to my surprise,
I got a handwritten letter and kind of a trembling hand vide and I still have
it.
I said that I can put it up on the screen.
It actually,
uh,
and uh,
he said,
my apologies.
Very polite and did a
diplomatic,
it's my apologies for not answering your letter,
but my health is poor.
And,
uh,
that was a long letter.
He said,
I'm trying to remember where I got the idea.
And he said,
I think it probably came from some of our coffee hours at the London School of
Economics in the 1920s.
He said,
we were discussing that.
And he said,
I thought it was in a book that my wife and I translated from the Swedish,
uh,
in the 1930s.
They said,
I looked and it's not there,
is there?
He said,
I guess maybe it is my id.
All right.
So the first person to write it up,
uh,
and then he died shortly thereafter,
so I got to him Justin time.
Uh,
so I,
I thought I would describe forward rates,
uh,
in terms of the,
coffee hour at the London School of Economics in the 20s.
Okay.
So,
uh,
this is jr Hicks talking.
Uh,
so the year is 1925.
Okay.
Uh,
and we're talking about investing in discount bonds,
uh,
and we're going to put a hundred pounds.
Okay.
Uh,
now suppose,
ah,
okay.
The idea that Hicks invented is that there are implicit in the term structure,
there are future interest rates already quoted.
I showed you the term structure.
I showed you a one year,
a treasury bill rate for,
for uh right now.
And uh,
that's not right now,
but you can see I have a one year and a two year treasury bill rate.
The idea of a forward right is that implicit in that term structure is also a
quote for the one year rate one year.
Hence,
because if you look at the two year rate,
can't you infer back what interest rates are going to be in one year?
Because the two year rate is,
um,
you've got the one year rate and the two year,
right?
So between the two,
what's left,
it's the difference between those two somehow reflects what interest rates will
be between one and two.
So what Hicks said,
okay,
this is a coffee hour conversation at the London School of Economics.
He said it's right now in 1925 but if you want to invest or borrow a in 1926,
uh,
I can do it for you.
I can lock in the interest rate right now.
Okay?
Okay.
So let's say,
okay,
I expect,
suppose I expect to get a hundred pounds in 1926.
Here we are sitting in 1925 and I want to today in 1925 Larkin,
the investment return that I will get when I invest a hundred pounds.
Okay?
Okay.
And so what we want to do,
this is what Hicks discovered.
I can do the following transaction to lock in in 1925 the interest rate between
1926 and 27.
So here we are sitting in 1925.
I'm going to buy in 25
this amount of two period bonds,
two year bonds,
one plus r two
squared,
uh,
over one plus r one.
Okay?
These will mature and be worth $100 and 26.
I'm going to short
how much I'm going to short,
short one,
one period bond.
This is the number.
This is the number of bonds I have to buy.
Okay.
And so,
uh,
let's analyze this track.
That's all I have to do.
And I locked in the interest rate.
Okay.
Are One is the,
the yield and the one period bond,
uh,
and r two is the yield and the two period bond.
So the price of the two period bond is one,
Oliver,
one plus r two squared.
And the price of the one period bond is one over one plus r one.
So if I buy this amount of one of two period bonds,
how much does it cost me?
It cost me one over one plus r one.
And if I short,
uh,
the,
one period bond,
it cancels out.
So I've made no net purchase.
And in 1925,
right,
I bought a number of two period bonds such that the value of my purchase exactly
equals the proceeds that I get from shorting the one period behind.
So I've made a zero transact [inaudible] wealth transaction.
It hasn't affected my portfolio,
uh,
my cash position at all.
What happens then in that's in 1925?
So,
uh,
there's no cash flow,
no cashflow at all.
Okay.
In 26,
what happens?
Well,
in 26,
um,
the,
uh,
I've shorted the one period bond and so,
um,
I have to pay out $1 now,
but that's exactly what I wanted to do.
Remember I said I'm doing this because I expect to have,
uh,
a hundred pounds.
I said one day I'm going to have to pay out a hundred pounds because this one
period bond worth a hundred pounds principle is coming due.
So I have to pay it out.
Uh,
but that's what I wanted to do.
Cause I said I have 100 pounds to invest.
Uh,
nothing happens to the,
uh,
to the,
to period bond because it just continues to mature.
So in 26,
in 1926,
I've,
hey,
100 pounds.
Okay.
What happens in 1927?
Now,
uh,
what happens is,
I now get the maturity of this band.
Um,
so,
um,
uh,
what I get,
I've,
I have,
um,
I have purchased this number of,
so I'm going to get a hundred pounds
times that month there.
The number of bonds,
one plus r two squared all over one plus r one.
So you can see that by doing this transaction,
I have locked in a return between 26 and 27.
I did it in 25 but I've got the,
I've got it set up so that they will pay a 100 pounds in 26 and I'll get this in
27.
So he calls the forward rate.
Okay.
Equals one plus r two squared.
Oliver One plus r one.
All right.
This is Hicks discovery.
I mean,
you might say this should have been obvious to someone,
but it was never been written up well before.
So what Hicks said is that in these terms structures,
you don't just have today's interest rate.
This is a map.
Actually,
I've just showed the one period they had one period forward,
right?
But you could do it over any combination and you can get forward rates of any
maturity at any future date.
Uh,
and so,
um,
so that it was his insight and it comes back then to Hick's book value and
capital in 1939 he said that we should think that the,
the,
the simplest story of the term structure of interest rates,
which he expounded there is that forward rates equal expected future interest
rates.
And so that means that in the simple as that,
that's called the expectations theory of the term structure,
it says that the forward rate,
which you can compute from today's newspaper,
uh,
or from today's website,
you can compute the forward rates for all future dates.
And what he says is those forward rates are what people think interest rates
will be in the future.
And that's called the expectations theory of that term instruction forward
rates,
equal expected future spot rate.
So if you're looking at the December,
2003,
what's going on,
it's very clear.
And that is the Fed had just cut interest rates to 1%.
It was an unusual,
it was much talked about,
people didn't expect that to hold.
And so the,
so people thought,
well,
it's going to still be down at three,
a 1%,
maybe in three months.
So you can see the,
uh,
the term structure doesn't go up between,
overnight and three months.
But they are expecting that the Fed has eventually,
and they were right.
Of course in this case,
the Fed is eventually going to raise rates.
So the,
the upward sloping term structure means that the foreign rates are at higher
levels.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
that's the expectations theory.
Uh,
fine.
but he also,
uh,
talked about,
um,
another theory in his 1939 book,
uh,
which is,
where's the expectations theory,
but there's also a in liquidity premium theory to get more chalky.
Okay.
And this is the theory that,
uh,
there's,
there's risk in longer term bonds and so that,
uh,
there's a,
there's a tendency for upward sloping term structure is a tendency
for upward slope,
even if expectations are flat.
So that according to the expectations theory augmented with a liquidity
preference,
um,
the uh,
uh,
the,
this,
this strongly upward sloping term structure in 2003 would reflect two things.
One is that people expect interest rates to go up and secondly that uh,
uh,
interest rates,
a longer term bonds are riskier.
And so,
uh,
there's also another effect pushing interest rates up.
The last thing I want to talk about is just running out of time here.
I want to,
I mentioned this before,
your
midterm exam,
which,
which is next Monday and covers everything through this lecture.
Uh,
something about inflation and interest rates.
inflation,
we'll call that a PI inflation rate.
Inflation rate is high.
So right now it's something like 2% or it's a little bit higher last year,
but maybe,
maybe it will be 2% going forward.
The real interest rate
computed from nominal rates is equal to one plus the nominal rate
divided by one plus the inflation rate.
So it corrects for inflation.
So if you have an interest rate,
this is approximately equal to
one plus the real interest rate
one.
Plus the real interest rate is equal to one,
plus the nominal interest rate divided by one plus the rate of inflation.
And we would say the real interest rate
equals the nominal rate approximately equals nominal rate
minus the inflation rate.
Okay.
Uh,
so if we have,
um,
right now,
uh,
if we go back to our current term structure,
well this isn't complete if you're looking at the current term structure was
interesting.
Look how this is.
As of earlier this year,
the,
uh,
the federal funds rate was at around 4% and it has this huge drop in the term
structure and then it starts to be upward sloping.
Why is that?
That's because on the date that I got this term structure,
everybody knew the Fed was cutting rates and they got it right.
The Fed was cutting rates to 3%.
They knew it was coming,
but not today.
Uh,
so,
um,
uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
right now,
we have a federal funds rate of about 3% and the inflation rate of around 3%.
So right now the real interest rate is close to zero.
Finally,
I just wanted to say that we have also a kind of bond,
but an indexed bond,
uh,
which is,
an a band who's coupons are indexed to inflation.
And with an index bond,
you don't have to do this calculation to get the real rate.
The,
the yield to maturity and an index bond is already in real terms because the
coupons are indexed to inflation.
And my final slide is a flat,
a picture of the first index bond.
Uh,
uh,
this is issued by the state of Massachusetts.
I actually own this bond.
I bought it for $1,000 on a website because I was interested in index bonds.
I could've,
I could've brought it to class and showed her too.
But this was issued in during the revolutionary war to help finance the war.
And what happened with the u s government or the Massachusetts government had
created high inflation during the war and nobody wanted to lend money to it.
So they create your eight a price index.
It says,
the price index contained,
uh,
this amount of beef,
this amount of sheeps,
well,
this,
this amount of the sole leather and this amount of corn,
that was a con,
that was the first consumer price index ever use for financial contracts.
But we now have something else called the consumer price index.
This bond was paid off in if Massachusetts didn't fail to pay on it,
uh,
in 1784,
I guess.
Uh,
and,
um,
but anyway,
so,
uh,
index bonds are about 15% of the u s national,
I'm sorry,
about 8% of the u s national debt,
about 15% of the UK national debt.
And they are very important,
but still a minority of all of our corporate,
of our fixed incomes.
Okay.
So that concludes this lecture.
And,
uh,
I won't be here on Monday,
but we'll have our lecture in this classroom.
Uh,
uh,
on Monday.